und damit jo Leute was geht herzlich
Willkommen zu ein neen Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut erstmal sorry
eigentlich wäre dieses Video schon eher
gekommen aber wir hatten ein paar
buchungsprobleme das wurd stoniert dann
kam wieder was dazwischen hier in
Thailand ist das alles nicht so einfach
wie man sich gerne vorstellt oder
meistens gewöhnt ist gut in Europa läuft
auch oft was schief aber hier ist es
wirklich echt so du buchst irgendwas und
dann ist erstmal so fifty fifty ob das
überhaupt durchgeht und manchmal kriegst
du dann eine Bestätigung die dann
irgendwann aber wieder stoniert wird
also es war die letzten Tage hier alles
ein ziemliches hin und her wir sind auf
jeden Fall immer noch auf kotao in
Thailand wunderschöne Insel wie ihr hier
sehen könnt also auch gerade hier am
Strand unser Hotel es war echt nice also
ist jetzt kein krasses Hotel einfach nur
gut gelegen entspannte Zimmer man konnte
gut schlafen es war nicht zu heiß hier
genau jetzt ist aber so langsam an der
Zeit Thailand zu verlassen weil wir
reisen ja weiter und zwar nach Japan am
einfachsten wä es jetzt natürlich von
hier aus mit dem Boot nach kosamui zu
fahren und von dort aus dann einfach
schnell nach Bangkok zu fliegen das wird
auch recht fix gehen ich glaube da
werden wir in dre oder vier Stunden
wieder in Bangkok aber natürlich nicht
mit mir unser Plan ist folgender wir
werden jetzt von Coto aus mit dem
nachtboot hanester fahren nach atani
kleiner funf genau dieses nachtboot ist
vor knapp einem Monat einfach gekenntt
und untergegangen also ohne Scheiß jetzt
ich kann euch immer ein paar Videos
einblenden od ein paar Fotos dieses Boot
gibt's jetzt logischerweise nicht mehr
das liegt jetzt irgendwo auf dem Boden
hier aber jetzt gibt's ein neues ich
hoffe das ist besser also es war hier
vor ein Monat wohl ziemlich stürmisch
jetzt gerade geht's eigentlich und dann
ist da Wasser drauf gelaufen immer mehr
und irgendwann ist es untergegangen auf
jeden Fall steht heute nach nachtbot an
ich bin echt mal gespannt das wird
absolut kein Luxus oder so das wird
einfach nur Kabine neben Kabine mit
anderen Menschen habe ich auch so noch
nie gemacht auf dem Boot ich war auch
noch nie nachts auf dem Boot also ich
freue mich auf auf jeden Fall wenn ich
wieder in Bangkok bin von suratani
geht's dann weiter mit dem Nachtzug der
fährt dann auch noch mal ich meine 10
Stunden von suratani nach Bangkok und
dann fliegen wir von Bangkok aus nach
Tokyo das ist der Plan schauen wir mal
ob das alles klappt aber ich habe schon
Bock Leute let's go bye
bye
recommendation ich ma hier eine
recommendation leute wenn ihr mal auf
Koto sein solltet sind hier wie das noch
Lücke Boutique Hotel kann man auf jeden
Fall empfehlen also Pre natürlich ein
bisschen teurer als so Hostels aber der
Wasserdruck ist besser als zu Hause
übrigens wichtige Information unsere
Reisepläne haben sich doch noch geändert
und zwar fährt diese fre auf die wir
gebucht sind heute von kotao nicht nach
suratani ich habe eben einen Anruf
bekommen und wir müssen jetzt einmal
rüber nach kopangan das ist halt die
Nachbarinsel ja ist natürlich ein
bisschen ärgerlich weil wir dadurch
schon bisschen eher los müssen ist aber
die gleiche fre und da fahren wir jetzt
hin was hast gesagt dass ich mein 40 Kil
Kaffer nicht schleppen muss ja bis jetzt
fahren wir eigentlich aber ganz gut mit
unseren Gepäckstücken hier wir haben
unsere Sachen einmal waschen müssen
aber ja ach so und in Japan müssen wir
natürlich wärmere Sachen holen weil da
sind nur
11° so und jetzt ab aufs nachtboot
übrigens schon mal als kleine Vorwarnung
es gibt keine Aircondition okay wir
liegen mit 30 oder 40 fremden Menschen
in so riesenbetten und es könnte
passieren dass wir singen können aber
das kommt nur einmal im Monat vor also
die Chance dass das passiert ist relativ
überschaub zur
Beruhigung so das ist auf jeden Fall
glaube ich schon mal unser Boot was
jetzt kurz uns rüber bringt da ich würde
mir noch eben einen Kaffee holen soevor
wir losfahren gibt noch ein Eis
Cappuccino auf jeden Fall finde ich
heißen Kaffee hier irgendwie mal eklig
oder nicht so lecker aber dieser kalte
den können die richtig gut zaubern sieht
finde ich auch aus wie bei Starbucks nur
besser und deutlich günstiger der kostet
knpp 2 € aber auch für thailändis schon
teuer hier auf den
Insel okay dann wollen wir mal tschüss
Koto es war wunderbar hier geile Insel
check das mal aus wenn ihr die Chance
dazu habt für mich mein Favorit hier
Thailand kopangan right okay thank
[Musik]
you
okay mittlerweile angekommen auf
kopangan hier gibt jetzt noch einen
kleinen Zwischenstop sehr sehr lecker
sieht das aus glaube ich ist zwar
deutsches Essen aber ja muss auch mal
sein was war das eben für ein
Geisteskranker Sonnenuntergang oder also
ich glaub das war der beste
Sonnenuntergang den wir je gesehen haben
ich hoffe ich hab gut draf bekommen und
ihr konntet das gut sehen war echt krass
also vor allem in echt das zu sehen
jetzt gleich geht aufs nightboard das
ist gerade schon angekommen schauen wir
mal ja schauen wir mal schauen wir mal
okay aufgegessen wir haben jetzt
mittlerweile F Uhr gleiches Boarding
leider haben wir überhaupt keine Ahnung
ob es auf dem Boot was zu essen gibt ich
gehe mal davon aus wenn es was gibt dann
nur zu trinken ihr habt ja schon Bild
gesehen also das ist wirklich alles sehr
sehr einfach auf unserem First Class
Luxusdampfer du kannst schwimmen ne ich
kann schwimmen genau deswegen geht's
jetzt hier noch zu 7-Eleven bisschen was
einkaufen für die Leute die 7-Eleven
nicht kennen das gibt's in Thailand
überall vor jedem 7-Eleven gibt's auch
verschiedene Hunde ATM Automaten und ein
Automaten und wir holen uns jetzt was e
hier na schmeckt Kollege sollen wir hier
die nightboat Edition nehmen thank you
das hier sieht auch krass aus ne wenn
man hier in kopangan ankommt läuft man
erstmal durch dieses Tor da hängt dann
auch immer so ein Foto vom König dran
wobei die den jetzigen König irgendwie
alle haten also das kriegt man so mit
wenn man hier bisschen mit Locals redet
keine Ahnung der ist irgendwie immer in
Bayern und macht da also der ist nie
hier kein Kommentar alex ist hier
todesra ach so stimmt wir haben jetzt
auf jeden Fall eine Stunde 10 vor
Abfahrt aber im Internet steht dass man
am besten früh da sein soll weil es
kriegt nicht jeder einen Platz und ich
habe jetzt keinen Bock in diesem
nachtboot 8 Stunden zu stehen deswegen
gehen wir jetzt bisschen eh hin wobei
ich auch wirklich mal gespannt bin wie
gut das eigentlich gebucht ist weil es
halt echt eine lange Fahrt das sind nur
150 km oder so und wir brauchen einfach
8 Stunden oder 9
Stunden also das hier ist schon mal eins
der Boote also sein Kollege ist halt
letztens untergegangen und von ihm sein
Cousin also ich glaube das da ist unser
Boot sieht ja eigentlich so aus als W
wir die ersten das stimmt suratani da
steht ah
Ticket hello how are
you very
good
people people not okay
okay
okay thank you ja das doch gut also das
ist für ich muss sagen das ist für mich
auch wirklich eine Erfahrung ich war
noch nie auf so Dampfer das sieht ja
wirklich verrückt aus Leute schaut mal
ich ma mal den
Anfang und
schwitzig so hey hello
upstairs
okay oh
m
Alter wir sind fast die
ersten ey wie
verrückt warm ne welchen Platz nehmen
wir
lings laufverkehr ja geh mal ja hast du
recht
ja guck mal hier wenn die Ventilatoren
an sind dann geht's ja das coole ist
ich ich flieg auf jeden Fall zurück mit
Swiss first habe ich gestern gebucht
ungefähr das
gleiche
ja ich mehr oder weniger ich hab also
hätte schlimmer sein können schlimmer
sauber ja stimmt bis
später
noch mal ein kleines Update wir warten
hier gerade vor dem Boot da drin ist es
echt warm und hier draußen wird noch so
ein kleines Lüftchen aber dieses Boot
ist halt wirklich aus safe schon boah
wie alt ist 50 60 Jahre und deswegen
wundert es mich auch nicht dass da bei
wen Seegang mal was passieren kann aber
heute ist die Sea ruhig noch noch
Toilette so sieht auf jeden Fall die
Toilette aus Leute Dusche darf natürlich
auch nicht fehlen ja und ich glaube
abspülen kann man nicht da muss man
einfach so Wasser reinkippen hening hat
gerade noch gefragt ob die hier an Bord
auch was zu trinken verkaufen und da
meinten die nee nicht mehr es ist mal
einer betrunken ins Wasser gefallen
unterwegs und dann haben wir gefragt ja
und Wasser nee auch nicht also hier
gbt's gar nichts und bevor es losgeht
erstmal gucken wie es in der Bundesliga
so läuft das finde ich auch so lustig
hier ist es total warm es ist mitten in
der Nacht und man kann einfach
bundesliger gucken ja es sind echt viele
locs auch hier oben hast du
recht also ich zähle jetzt aber viel
mehr als 40 Personen oder ja das stimmt
aber vielleicht re guck mal wie viele da
hinten noch kommen rechnen die auch sie
meinte vielleicht einfach 40 Tourist das
kommt dann hin oh 10 Werder Bremen hier
ginma der hat früher Youtube Videos
gemacht krank und heute schießt ein Tor
gegen Bayern ich das ist ja also
wirklich krass ey Props gehen raus ich
wä auch lieber Fußballer geworden nein
Spaß ich bin zufrieden ich bin zufrieden
also erstmal finde ich wirklich
interessant dass es hier tatsächlich
Strom gibt an Bord oder zumindest dass
man sein Handy laden kann also ich
schätze ich krieg dre oder vier Stunden
erholsamen Schlaf mehr nicht und du ich
und ete das ich sag mal so zwei wir
fahren jetzt los
schauangan und ja hoffentlich kommen wir
an es ist wirklich verdammt heiß hier
drin aber durch den fahwind kommt jetzt
ein bisschen kommt jetzt bisschen Kälte
rein so jetzt wird erstmal unser Ticket
kontrolliert muss auch sein ja weil von
hier aus kannst du zurückschwimmen wenn
du keins hast sind ja er 200 m das ist
die Frage was macht er denn wenn wir
jetzt kein Ticket hätten ja das sind
doch er zuin Dreh noch mal um weil h ein
BL weiß nicht aus dem Fenster raus mein
got das Wasser ist bisschen warm kannst
do
schaffen also was mir hier wirklich auf
dem Geist geht sind diese völlig
überdröhnten handygeräusche das ist aber
generell so in Thailand die haben
überhaupt kein Gefühl für Lärm es ist
überall einfach laut und hier hat jeder
sein Handy auf voller Lautstärke also
gut dass ich meine neu canceling airpods
dabei habe so ich habe meine große K
jetzt weggepackt wir hab jetzt noch die
GoPro hier erstmal weiß gar nicht ob wir
überhaupt noch irgendwas sehen könnt ja
gehen jetzt gleich schlafen oder
versuchen zumindest schon am Schaukeln
also wissen was die Leute durchgestanden
haben die vor einem Monat gekenttert
sind weil das ist hier spiegelglatt das
Wasser und es schaukelt das ist hier
eine richtige lpy die sind alle an i
Handys jetzt ganz schön Z schukel mit
der Tür
da eentlich dieür immer geschlossen sein
muss keer den Captain genau die Tür ist
das ich auf ich ze das mal all zusammen
hier die die Fraktion die schlafen schon
teilweise also es sind auf jeden Fall
über 100 Leute hier drauf hier unten
könnt ihr den Motor
sehen sieht doch ganz flott
aus also so langsam geht mir dies
Gebimmel da hinten auch auf den Sack
warte vor allem welche welches Handy ist
bitte so laut na ja mal gucken ob ich
ein Auge zurieg gute
[Musik]
Nacht ich glaube wir sind gleich schon
da hier ist jetzt das
rich
und geschlafen ja eine
[Musik]
Stunde so eigentlich sind wir jetzt da
aber irgendwie drehen durch bisschen ne
ja
ich so sieht übrigens die Kajute hier
aus wir sind auf jeden Fall da was ich
nicht ganz verstehe ist warum die alle
nicht aussteigen na ja
bye au
scheißbot kannst du das Ticket einm
zeigen
jetzt habe ich mir gerade noch schön
meinen Kopf da gestoßen an diesem Boot
na ja auf jeden Fall sind wir jetzt
angekommen in zatani wir haben jetzt 5
Uhr morgens ich bin auf jeden Fall
eigentlich relativ wach von hier aus
geht eigentlich auch später der Zug
weiter wir wollten halt eigentlich einen
Tag hier bleiben aber ich glaube das
wird nichtich also wirklich schon jede
Menge los um 5 Uhr morgenens wobei gut
um 7 Uhr ist dann wahrscheinlich noch F
mal
los so was geht mittlerweile sind wir in
Bangkok eigentlich war der Plan von
abends noch mit dem Nachtzug nach
Bangkok zu fahren hätte ungefähr 10
Stunden gedauert ich habe den Nachtzug
natürlich auch im Voraus schon gebucht
wir hatten so eine eigene Sleeper cabin
das wäre denke ich auch ganz cool
gewesen und wäre dann eventuell noch in
diesem Video gelandet oder ich hätte
halt ein separates gemacht je nachdem
vielleicht W es auch auf meinem Alex wau
Kanal gekommen den ihr alle mal
abonnieren solltet abends als wir aufs
Boot gegangen sind kam dann aber eine
Mail dass die Sleeper cabin überbucht
ist aktuell sind hier einfach so viele
Backpacker unterwegs und anscheinend ist
alles voll und wir halt nur in diesen
Sitzwagen können und da dachte ich mir
dier ich setze mich nicht abends noch 12
Stunden in so ein Sitzwagen wir haben
auch beide leichte Erkältungssymptome
deswegen war es denke ich die richtige
Entscheidung einfach zu sagen wir
fliegen nach Bangkok und sind dann um 12
Uhr oder so ins Flugzeug gestiegen und
mittlerweile jetzt hier in Bangkok noch
ein kleines abschließendes Fazit zum
nachtbot also es war auf jeden Fall eine
Erfahrung die ich in meinem Leben nicht
vergessen werde und ich muss sagen ich
habe echt im Vergleich zu einigen
Nachtzügen besser gepennt einfach weil
als irgendwann die ganzen Thailänder
ihre Smartphones weggelegt haben und
auchgeschlafen haben es nicht so laut
war und durch dieses leichte Schwanken
des Bootes bin ich ziemlich schnell
eingeschlafen und habe vier Stunden
eigentlich fast durchgepennt was aber
wirklich extrem nervig war war diese
Rücksichtslosigkeit dieser ganzen
Thailand ich weiß nicht das liegt
wahrscheinlich einfach an deren Kultur
nur in Deutschland würde man natürlich
einem nachtboot ich habe keinen Plan ob
es sowas überhaupt gibt mitten in der
Nacht sein Handy nicht auf volle
Lautstärke stellen um die anderen Leute
nicht zu stören aber denen ist es halt
völlig egal weder ihren eigenen Freunden
gegenüber noch irgendwelchen Touristen
ob Sie Ihr Handy auf 100 dzbild Stellen
oder nicht sonst war es auf jeden Fall
ganz lustig das beschreib es denke ich
ganz gut ich muss es aber hier in
Thailand nicht noch mal machen danke
fürs zuschauen ich hoffe das Video hat
Euch gefallen wir sehen uns dann in
Japan wieder da kommen echt coole Videos
abonniert sehr gerne den Kanal Däumchen
nach oben würde mich freuen haut rein
ciao